how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have some really big and really
exciting news in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe phase four has been officially
revealed and now we have some exciting
news about some upcoming phase 5
projects including the possibility of a
Hulk series coming to Disney plus a lot
of stuff is going to be happening at
Disney's d23 event next week so let's
break down all the reports real quick if
you'd like a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero or
villain I'm picking a winner at 500,000
subscribers so Disney's d23 event is a
huge fan event that Disney does every
two years and just like two years ago
Marvel gets some time during this event
to talk about their upcoming projects
and it's widely expected that we're
going to get some talk about the
upcoming phase 5 projects this year and
according to a report we can expect some
major announcements at this year's d23
event now we know that Marvel has a lot
planned out for their Disney Plus shows
for phase 4 they have the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier
wandah vision Loki and a Hawkeye series
that are all going to be a part of phase
4 connected to the MCU but we do also
know that they have phase 5 all planned
out the president of Marvel Studios
Kevin Feige has already said that they
have the next five years planned out
this of course means more Disney Plus
shows that are going to be connected to
the MCU in phase 5 and according to the
site MCU cosmic comm Marvel has some
very big plans an active development for
Disney Plus that will be revealed soon
now the site does not mention how soon
but of course we acknowledge that the
d23 Expo is next week and although
nothing is confirmed there is a
possibility that they could talk about
this big announcement next week and
according to MCU cosmyk we may have an
idea of what this announcement could be
and it could be a Hulk solo series last
year when there were reports about an
Eternals movie being in development and
a solo Hawkeye project being in
development as well there was also a
report that Marvel Studios had plans for
the Hulk after Avengers 4 now the Hulk
is kind of tricky because Marvel doesn't
exactly own all of the rights to the
Hulk they don't have the rights to do a
hulk solo film only the rights to use
him in another movie which is why we see
him in infinity war and in game
and thor ragnarok because technically
they're not Hulk movies however Disney
may have found a little loophole here
since Disney cannot make a solo Hulk
film perhaps they can make a solo hulk
series this way they could still dive
into a major Hulk story that is still
connected to the MCU this is something
that everybody would absolutely love the
Hulk is a fan favorite and a lot of
people think that he was done injustice
in Avengers infinity war and Avengers
end game but a Disney Plus series that
is only about the Hulk could open up so
much possibilities and could definitely
be a way to redeem the Hulk we know that
Marvel and Mark Ruffalo have a lot of
plans for the Hulk still that have not
been used several months ago in and ask
me anything on reddit Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios mentioned
that him and Mark Ruffalo sat down and
talked about ideas for the Hulk and
remember he was saying all of this after
Avengers endgame and he said some of the
ideas they have used but some of them
they have not yet used so there are
still a lot of plans for the Hulk and
according to this recent report
something could be in development and
that something could be a Hulk solo
series on Disney Plus now of course this
may not be the case the big announcement
may not be a Hulk solo series we know
that Kevin Feige has said that Marvel is
going to introduce miss Marvel into the
MCU and perhaps their plans to
originally introduced her are to
introduce her in a Disney Plus series
this way they can give us a little
backstory that is connected into the MCU
and then move her into a film but sadly
right now all of this talk about what
the big announcement could be is just
speculation
hopefully this big announcement from
Disney come soon at the d23 event next
week and if not hopefully it comes soon
after and hopefully it's a Hulk solo
series so leave your thoughts and
predictions in the comments down below
also comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof